good morning Millennials
good morning Millennials how's it going
today on this wonderful bright and sunny
Wednesday no no cuz it's really Tuesday
because we only have our Tuesday it is
though essentially right better than
it's Wednesday so it's a gift I don't
see it that way but I appreciate your
optimism I mean I don't know how I'm
even being optimistic I've never felt
worse in my life Mitch oh so crazy is
I'm doing dry January if for those you
are I mention that yeah because I
started out like obviously I don't want
to drink it's a month before my wedding
and then I got the dry January app one
of the toasters was talking about it and
now I track every day so now I really
just want to like stay dry for January
and then maybe I'll have a drink or two
in February but I just want to say I did
dry January that's so crazy because like
I feel like people who do dredge anyway
like talk about it all the time and like
they're annoying but you're not I know
so I fun fact about me I'm doing try
January I was supposed to but I didn't
last till generate fourth cuz the MER
girl UN's birthday wasn't my fault oh
right that's fair um so I haven't had a
drink in like over three weeks and I've
never felt worse in my life yesterday
like I had symptoms of what I could have
been the worst hangover ever but it was
just life mm-hmm so what's the point
like if I'm gonna feel hungover for some
reason or another anyway like I might as
well have had a good time for at least
like three hours I agree so I don't know
if I would advocate I'd try January I'll
let you know at the end of the month but
so far I feel like [ __ ] I've really
never felt worse like yesterday when we
started the show like I didn't have a
and then it was just a migraine sort of
day I understand it was so hard I mean
Theo tried to really cure me and help me
and he wrote me a prescription for love
and happiness I think he wrote you a
prescription actually for some vitamins
but it did the love and happiness
honestly like it wasn't strong enough
I'm gonna need to up my dosage and to
start taking more of my vitamins one of
my resolutions was like to get my
vitamin [ __ ] together I've always taken
milk thistle because so many people tell
me it's a good thing but I really find
like I have so many like bodily problems
that I think can only be healed
naturally do you know what I mean
yeah like the the tiredness the lack of
energy the fatigue I really feel like it
could only be something like Eastern
medicine can do do you know what I mean
no it's like it's the sort of thing
where yes you need to yell match
but then also you need to start taking
vitamins like we're at a point in our
lives where like we're aging like our
bones are getting brittle but you
definitely don't have enough nutrients
the bottles like all over the place and
it like takes up the whole kitchen and
it's so annoying as someone who like has
OCD I can't deal with the amount of
sheer space that vitamins take up like
and not even in the medicine cabinets
there's no room for it that's why you
need care of so I got I actually got
care of I got a huge like stack and the
little like it's actually good because
if I forget it in the morning I started
my person then in the middle of the day
I'll be like I'll be like Raven having a
vision and I remember I'm only like a
week in and I and I definitely feel
better a because I'm just doing
something every day and it feels good to
like remember to do something yeah and
be I took they give you a quiz like what
do you want your vitamins for and I did
I took it really seriously like a brain
it's a personalized quiz you know we
love we love a personalized quiz over
here brain function memory that was my
number one [ __ ] to energy like crashing
at 2 or 3 o'clock yeah and it's so funny
I ended up getting milk thistle in my
even though I already take it so now I
got rid of my other milk thistle and I
just take the one that they give me oh
that's great yeah so if you guys want to
get care of we obviously have a code for
you because we care about you me want
you to feel good our promo code is toast
so if you go to take care of comm use
promo code toast on screen you will be
able to get 25 percent off your first
month so they send you an entire month
of supplies so it's like I love not
having to think about things that's my
favorite thing 25 percent of your first
month of personalized care of vitamins
take care of calm and enter promo code
toast I started using care of like six
months ago and I really wish I had had
that promo code then you total it's like
it's that's a hefty promo code yeah 20
pepper expand and now like I've slowed
I've been remiss in taking my vitamins
but this is a good reminder like I
[ __ ] you need vitamins I'm and
something's wrong with me you know I
just I wonder if there will ever come a
day where I feel good are there people
who walk around like people who have set
alarms and they feel good know where
they're like I'm not tired
yeah I'll never know what that's like
but I just want to know if there are
people out there who don't spend their
entire morning's complaining I there are
okay should we try and beat them today
no I can't
today like I truly like never felt worse
tomorrow maybe yeah anyways long day
yesterday so much great TV was on yes I
did catch up on Vanderpump rules and
siesta key and I have somebody thought
it was really good we'll recap
everything after we hit you with the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
eh are you ready for it yeah okay update
from yesterday's story Chris Brown has
been released after Paris rape complaint
the singer denies the allegation
American singer Chris Patten was
released after being detained in Paris
over allegations of aggravated rape and
drug offenses judicial sources confirmed
to CBS News on Tuesday the sources said
Brown and two others were released from
custody and the public prosecutor will
continue investigating the complaints
which Brown denies he denied the
incident an Instagram post on Tuesday
afternoon in all caps want to make it
perfectly clear dot this is false and a
whole lot of cap never for my daughter
and my family this is so disrespectful
and is against my character and morals
thoughts what exactly are the character
and morals of someone who has been
accused of like battery and assault and
it's like he acts like he's this
upstanding citizen and he is this
wonderful reputation that is now being
tarnished no I think when you beat the
[ __ ] out of Rihanna and those pictures
of her when fire like that's probably
like when you know your reputation
started being tarnished yeah now it's
already tarnished we hate you I mean I
respect you no but I mean this is really
bad time for a rape allegation to be
coming out like today you know like if
you just stayed quiet maybe he could
have missed all of this you know me two
times up right but I feel as though this
is just a bad time for him oh so what is
it should this is all cap did he mean
crap I have no idea I was trying to
understand maybe he was just like really
upset I'm just like splurt of that I
thought he meant all cap like in caps
lock because that's oh that's the key
that he used you think hey that's what I
thought
unclear whatever he's maintaining his
innocence I for one don't believe him
um and I don't think the world really
does either and I think that speak on
behalf of the toasters let me say we
don't believe you Chris Brown yeah I
don't believe Chris Brown cuz you know
fool me once shame on was he allowed to
leave the country like go back home yeah
he I mean I think so he's out of court
so I had a jail so what can they do
please whatever I like truly like I am
here's another new year's resolution
when does it stop
what does it become too late to like
making New Year's resolutions 2020 okay
I think you make a new one I am NOT
going to perpetuate the fame of monsters
like Chris Brown like he keeps making
money because people keep us into his
music and keep making him popular and
I'm no longer gonna talk about him how
about that yeah China there's a lot of
people like that including Brian singer
also bad babby Danielle Broly what about
her look we need to stop talking about
her I never ever talk about her I just
read something she got like a million
dollar makeup deal or something with you
know done that's good
thank you I never talked about her and
they feel so glad about it nobody the
world does and world star needs to stop
because they're perpetuating her payment
I don't follow world sorry I feel it's
like the best Instagram account the I
followed it for a few days and there was
just way too much they post over like
over 20 times a day did you watch Jimmy
Kimmel on watch what happens live no but
I saw John Mayer showed up at the guitar
okay the first half of the episode was
probably like the worst 15 minutes of
television I've ever really especially
considering like it should have been the
best time premium late-night host
sitting together getting to know one of
them right like a few weird things
happen like first of all Jimmy Kimmel
just wasn't being funny and like it was
really weird oh maybe that's cuz he's
not funny and he has a TV show where
they literally added him to perfection
and have 25 writers who write every
mediocre joke for him maybe I don't know
that's why I'm just not sure the second
thing was that they've kept on putting
they're like watch what happens I'd like
their game things like when he blew and
they would play a game they would like
put their sticker on top of the screen
and like it says something like it's a
great
you've been China and it's like China
but Jimmy Kimmel sake talking me like
missed what he was saying he was like
just so when I was like 2 whoever was in
the controller like just stop
your [ __ ] games for a second like you
don't need to see the graphic 5,000
times let but the man speak and then
Andy was playing these games with him
where he was like people you would never
have on your show and they had to go
back and forth for 30 seconds and Andy
had all his answers planned out already
he had like obvious everyone who's ever
been China since the dawn of time right
Danielle Brooke holy and Jimmy Kimmel is
just being thought a thought about it
for the first time and it was just like
he was just like Donna Tom jr. Eric
trump like he's just going through all
the choices go cuz he couldn't think of
anything like that was so unfair that
Andy had like ours to repair he had
writers and then Jimmy came us to come
up on the spot of everyone else are my
very possible that they did get him the
questions in advance like you just
didn't prepare I don't it really didn't
seem like it it was so it was really
strange
it was so at first I wanna say like I
love watch out enzyme and I want to
watch every episode but like you know
how uninterested I am to watch [ __ ]
episode of Jimmy Kimmel like you're a
talk show host
for a reason like you're not the talent
like we're not interested in you or your
life or your family or your opinions it
only got better when he started being
like host E and turning the tables on
Andy being like my guy and he's
interesting I got you these gifts like
for the beat he did like a gag gift and
then a real gift and it was just so
strange then they were like and here's a
sneak peak of Vanderpump rules next week
and I was so excited excited just seen
Madden from Pro sites like sneak peek
yeah and they've got cut to a picture on
James and then it goes to commercials
like it didn't work oh the preview and
then they came back and they were like
sorry about that and Jimmy Kim was like
where is my Vanderpump rules preview I'm
like seriously we never got it and they
still want it oh my god it was just like
one thing on that bad and spiritually I
understand it was really upsetting
no Jimmy Kimmel honestly like I don't
[ __ ] with him whatsoever I think he's so
not funny and I've heard some things you
know really yeah I don't I don't like
either of the Jimmy's you know I like
Jimmy Fallon I Bailey's I'm just not a
late-night kind of guy no me neither I'm
James Corden girl Oh shame but then like
his shows too long
no I'm a GM sorry I'm a James Corden
YouTube channel gotta go exactly we're
just digital through and through yeah
okay speaking of people that must be
canceled and we will help further along
their cancellation because you know the
world is just so eager to cancel people
except people who deserve to be
cancelled you know except for people who
have hurt other people no no the old
like there's mmm
mm excuse me mm there's like the 1% of
the world of people who are actually
evil and need to be canceled and for
some reason like the world turns a blind
blind eye to that 1% but then there's
like people like who have [ __ ] up in
the world just like immediately cancels
them a lot one Brian singer you know
what I'm saying more like Dan Schneider
or our Kelly no but like the world was
cancelled him now it's taking a really
long time it is I'm sorry the comments
are going off about something about a
nurse okay and I feel like I might know
what it is and I just need to make sure
oh my god nurse arrested in the case of
incapacitated woman who gave birth okay
sorry not to be ignorant but male nurse
or female nurse because then you think
nurse you think a woman no it's a male
nurse okay so they arrested for the rape
yes okay okay oh my god okay we have a
bonus story the nurse we're actually
gonna do an update on the the woman who
gave birth in a coma cuz her family said
that she's actually not in the coma
oh but she's in likes uh I was gonna get
into it but this is more important a
nurse arrested in the case of an
incapacitated woman who gave birth
Phoenix police say a licensed practical
nurse has been arrested on a charge of
sexual assault in the impregnation of an
incapacitated woman who gave birth last
month at a long-term health care
facility Phoenix Police Chief Jerry
Williams said Wednesday that
investigators arrested 36 year old
Nathan Sutherland we have an Amen on one
count of sexual assault and one count of
vulnera vulnerable adult abuse Williams
said southern island worked at the
Hacienda health care facility where the
woman lived and had been providing care
to her the 20 29 year-old victim has
been incapacitated since the age of
three and gave birth to a boy at the
facility on December 29th Nathan said
Wow Wow the plot thickens and you know
it's just so crazy it's like this dude
oh yeah dude sorry I don't know why I'm
like so confused about the nurse thing
it's just there's just some things you
think like a nurse is a woman and I just
thought it was I'm sorry I'm just like
so ignorant and I'm so um like you know
um what's funny word I've just been so
brainwashed by the patriarchy like I
can't think of anything like you know
he went through nursing school like
years of probably
student loans hard work studying
literally just to get arrested do you
know what I mean
I mean yeah cuz he's obviously a junkie
and a disgusting sick [ __ ] but this is
definitely not his first instance of
abuse you think for sure well first of
all he was definitely abusing this woman
like it wasn't like he did it once and
she got pregnant right you know like
yeah are the odds right that's true she
would have to be like incredibly fertile
right so this isn't the first time no
and I'm sure like along his way he's 36
he probably had like 10 years of abuse
so you know like in prison there's a
hierarchy like if you like abuse a child
like they beat the [ __ ] out of you I
feel like this is really down low at the
bottom of the prison hierarchy they're
like you got a like an ill woman
pregnant you're a [ __ ] sick [ __ ] and
he's gonna get the shipping out of him
totally just they have a weird way of
serving justice in prison they do but I
wonder if this is a result of the DNA
tests or you know information that they
found because they did get samples from
everyone oh they did and wonder if you
like willingly gave his DNA sample like
knowing it's gonna come back to him
right cuz if he's a nurse he definitely
knows like he might as well confess and
like try and act like you were in love
or something or maybe like there's
footage of some security something yes I
think only person so he was so terrible
and like horrible and I'm glad justice
hasn't been served in a small way but
can you explain what you were gonna say
about the family saying she's not in a
coma yes
so that was supposed to be our fifth
story but the woman who gave birth at
the Arizona nursing facility is quote
not in the coma says the family the
family of an Arizona woman who gave
birth last month in a long-term health
care facility issued a statement saying
she is not in a coma
despite assert a shion's by police she's
in a vegetative state and medical
records stating she has been
unresponsive for decades quote the
victim hair the victims parents would
like to make clear that she's not in a
coma the family of the 29 year old
Native American woman said in a
statement through their attorney quote
she has significant intellectual
disabilities as a result of seizures
very early in her childhood she does not
speak but has some ability to move her
limbs in the head and neck
their daughter responds to sound and is
able to make facial gestures the
important thing is that she is a beloved
daughter I'll bait I'll be it with
significant intellectual disabilities oh
I always say I'll bet you do I think
it's one word it's a weird [ __ ] word
because they ll space please
I know I could be doing it all so it
sounds like someone's last name like
Jackie Albert it sounds like al Bayt
Nan's Oh which one was that
the cuter one or the the cuter one the
smaller one this both Albie Albie the
computer one and but Chris was the
smarter one the Chris head eschewed
together Albie got kicked out of Law
School
or something I thought the cuter one was
also the smarter one no whatever no
one's that lucky okay
I should eat first and then I remember
is uh I'll be it so she's like with it
picked up like yeah well she's at least
mentally there so this makes this even
worse completely because she was like
aware of the entire thing oh it couldn't
speak to and so she when she was eating
my flesh must have been an incredible
pain no she has feelings like sweet ride
to enjoy soft music and is capable of
responding to people she is familiar
where the story especially the story
gets worse and worse for sure
okay sorry it appears that Albie was the
hot and smart one Wow I'm so glad but I
don't but I remember them having the
conversation that he got kicked out of
law school I think he might've like but
he was still smart and hot so what did
Chris do for a living that's a
million-dollar question right I guess
you have to ask I think he's still
trying to figure it out okay
aren't we all um Wow I can't believe we
have a name I really wasn't expecting
this on this on this treasure as much no
I know she's just like I feel like a lot
of justice has been served in the past
couple weeks they found that girl in
Boston Olivia Livi
oh yeah but she was she was gone for
like a couple hours they found the
girl's name yeah and did you see there
was a $50,000 reward and the PIA luck
got herself out and she ran to the sim
family and they called the police and
the police gave her them the fifty
thousand and they said we don't want it
Jaime should get it for like school she
[ __ ] saved herself and now like the
government's getting involved they have
to figure out what to do with the 50
grand like if she if they don't give it
to this girl I'm protesting and do they
tax that I don't know and where does
that money come from yeah that is so
crazy it's always she's gonna need more
than fifty thousand though she lost both
of her parents and she needs like uh
extensive therapy yeah her picture like
haunts me you know yeah and
the same one every time you can't like
keep up with this story because it's
just it'll be the toasters and just
think like Millennials in general or
look really invested in like these types
of cases that go national and they like
follow along and they think that they
can help and a lot of times like people
get found to do - like Facebook posts
and [ __ ] yeah or if like everyone
recognizes this person's face then if
they ever go in public with their captor
maybe they have a chance you know and
are you do you find it like especially
in airports and just like restaurants in
general like are you seeing more signs
for like human trafficking like
helplessness no yeah like I was just on
the airplane and I had read a story a
couple weeks ago about this flight
attendant who like saved this woman's
life because the girl was up with a man
and there's like a lot of signs if you
like it because they have to travel with
the human with their captors and she was
so silent and like the Jew too ordered
the drink for her and like she like
wouldn't make eye contact in the girl
went to the bathroom wrote a message on
the mirror and when they landed the
police came and got the girl and so now
I guess because there's so much so many
human traffickers like have to take
airplanes commercial flights that
there's like all these like new signs
around airports like if you see
something like do this oh my god and I
was in a bathroom once and it was like
if you feel unsafe order this shot and
the waitress will know what you're
talking about I was like a fake shot
called like the ginger shot or whatever
oh the Angels shot they've got a date
you're not supposed to see the name it's
fine I've seen it yeah but it's only in
women's rooms so if I but I've seen it
on the Internet okay like there's like
this is amazing thing I mean they're
blowing up the spot yeah I've seen it
like like I know that's why I knew the
name I just said a different one because
I don't want to blow up the spot now
like a straight man's watching who's
gonna be like oh I was just something
was no they won't remember they'll be
like it couldn't be me there's
definitely an angel shot on the menu at
this footies yeah right no no I'm a nice
guy speaking of not nice we were in the
Bryan Singer hit with fresh allegations
of sex with underage boys Bryan Singer
the director of Bohemian Rhapsody up for
movie of the year very much still a
player in the industry is facing new
allegations in addition to the old
allegations that we've already heard
published in the Atlantic on Wednesday
that's the engaged in sexual misconduct
with
with underage boys in the report for a
man alleged that singer had sexual
encounters with them when they were
teenagers in the late 1990s one of the
men Victor Val Davina's says he was 13
he was a 13 year old extra on the set of
apt people when singer fondled his
genitals the three others accusers are
identified in the story by pseudonyms
one identified in the story as Annie
says that he had sex with singer when he
was 15 another man identified as Eric
says he was 17 when he began having sex
with the director singer would have been
31 at the time the third man ben alleges
that he and singer had oral sex when he
was 17 or 18 shook and he's more
gruesome details to the story feel free
to read them on your own you know it's
we get the gist so this is what I was
saying before it's like we live in this
like immediate cancel culture and it
really weirdly only applies to people
like who who didn't really like [ __ ] up
that bad and like there's margin for
error but like these evil people who are
like actually bad people and evil people
and I've done the most unforgivable
horrible things for years not just once
it's like everyone turns a blind eye for
sure and there's a stark difference
between hurting people physically and
hurting people with your words or just
like making a joke and like saying
something dumb and like [ __ ] up right
or like just saying saying something
mean and doing something cruel there's
like why is it the same punishment for
each not we are just cancellation right
yeah no not even right no I think but
these days we are more likely to
immediately cancel someone who said
something inappropriate than someone who
did something inappropriate right to
someone else wild wild we got to get a
handle on that you guys know Bryan
Singer is pit City and his face is also
like a big pit like you look at it and
you're like oh yeah you all have to
respect it I would never I never knew
what he looked like until right now but
they're always talking about him on
Twitter like yeah and Andy and I yeah
and he's really like a bad guy and rami
malek I just saw this right before right
before I sat down and I didn't get a
chance to read whole thing but did an
interview where they asked him about the
Brian singer of it all and he basically
said that Freddie Mercury like turned a
blind eye to Brian singer so he was
getting into the character so much that
he also turned a blind eye but that's
the dumbest answer but like to say hey
Jackie it's kind of like a smart answer
just like normal public
Sam Boyd I'm like cause it's like it
turns the question on its head and now
you don't know what to say max right no
it's not a bet it's not a bad answer no
well I wonder if Justin for Brian singer
will ever be justice for Bryan Singer's
big time yellow ever leaves I don't
think so I mean the documentary about it
the world can't understand someone's
Kroll until we see it in a six-part
lifetime series write that like spells
it out for you right okay all the
writing's on the wall
I'm not sure though suddenly I can't
breathe no we got to put together a
documentary that's what it is yeah
speaking of documentaries and our Kelly
taraji P Henson faces backlash after
comparing our Kelly to Harvey Weinstein
I saw this first posted by the toast
thank you very much Claudia oh it is an
honor taraji P Hansen sparked outrage
and confusion after she compared the use
of hashtag mute our Kelly hashtag -
hashtag mute Weinstein and need Harvey
Weinstein in since deleted Instagram
story posts the Empire star called out
the lack of post calling for the muting
of the disgrace Hollywood mogul who was
set to stand trial in May for sexual
assault
however the hashtag nude our Kelly
hashtag went viral after lifetime stock
e-series surviving our Kelly which
followed the stories of several victims
who accused the world's greatest crooner
of sexual abuse and predation confused
Twitter users came forward to call out
Henson who they believed missed the
entire point of the hashtags quote so if
new Weinstein had just as many posts as
our Kelly would that change Suraj's
opinion I'm confused
absolutely user there was like nuke our
Kelly is an actual campaign with done
being hashtag there's no such Harvey
Weinstein hashtag because there's so
there's no point to be made here taraji
up as if Weinstein still has the public
support not only that when I saw that I
was like okay and then I looked for
hashtag Harvey Weinstein there was 400
thousand posts using the hashtag hashtag
what he's just hard do you want scene so
it wasn't that like people aren't
talking about Harvey mind saying they're
talking about him just as if probably
not more than our Kelly there's not
using the hashtag mute Harvey right
that's on it that's not a hashtag that
makes us an mute has to do with his
music because our Kelly's a singer
Harvey once he makes films it would have
to be like turn off Harvey I'm like no
it's like one it's apples and oranges
but two like Harvey Weinstein is on his
way to try owned by the Harvey Weinstein
is literally the
face of the times that movement brings
the first person out and like it was
this huge thing like you don't make the
art give you a point is to be that like
we weren't hard enough on hire harvey
weinstein like i don't know what more we
could have done you know what that is a
point but not when it comes to everyone
see when it comes to like a cracker
brian's where are you brian singer
bring it if she I see what she's saying
I just didn't I didn't like her example
and also in the example she made there
was an inherent flaw and the flaw is
that mute Harvey was in a popular
hashtag because that wasn't what the
campaign was called so well I saw the
point she was trying to make the
campaign was called me too and times up
right and go out of millions Isis right
and Harvey's no longer working we don't
need to mute him yeah but we have to
mute our Kelly's music because like it's
still being put out because no one will
put a stop to it
right yeah apples and oranges my friend
yep
strange next I've been a little
light-hearted news well that was a heavy
fur story out of like darkness this
morning Chris Brown bride singer the
nurse the nurse and our Kelly and Harvey
Weinstein what a day but I love charge'
P Henson and honestly she do no wrong so
I forgive her I agree breaking down
ariana grande's newly unveiled thank you
next album tracklist okay ariana grande
has a new album coming out it's two
albums in six months I believe it's
coming out on Valentine's Day I had a
dream that I like found it like and I
like it's someone like leaked it on
Spotify and I was listening to it so
these are the names of the tracks
imagine we know it must miss needy NASA
bloodline fake smile bad idea makeup
ghost in in my head seven rings thank
you next break up with your girlfriend
on board
so NASA like enews was all up in arms
because one time Pete Davidson wore
sweatshirt that said NASA on it oh wow I
don't know if but that can't be a
correlation no in one of the weird
videos I watched about the hidden
meanings in seven rings video they said
that she's like a huge NASA fan like
she's obsessed with space okay she has
tweets about like how Pluto is the most
beautiful planet oh no wait it's Jupiter
and by the way Pluto not really a planet
anymore
yeah the drama sets drama I know there's
so much drama like with astrology
astronomy astrology is horoscopes
thought to astronomy in space what
could've shot me when I want you did
what'd you learn name the planets oh
let's try earth no no it's you have to
start from the from the closest like
from the beginning oh I'm sorry I don't
know oh oh if we're just naming pie
let's see if we came in Mars Venus
Uranus haha those red glass ones Earth
Jupiter Saturn Saturn Mercury Uranus
Neptune Pluto that's nine and now but
they say Pluto's not a one so that would
be I really feel like we need to get the
other planets like poppin cuz I can use
more options when it comes to places to
live I don't know just isn't cutting it
for me these days and with all the ice
caps melting we won't be here for that
much longer be really just start
settling on like Mars and some shows we
have to jump to Mars did I see it do you
say no yeah that's the first one I said
okay okay you ready for next story yeah
we're through it's exciting news for
those of you who eat non-kosher
McDonald's is giving away free bacon for
one hour today MacDonald says it's
giving away free bacon On January 29th
sorry not today from 4 p.m. to 5 p.m.
during that window the company says
customers can get two pieces of bacon on
the side of any order whether a burger
fillet a fish or a hot fudge sundae with
a side of bacon English the new the deal
is meant to highlight three new bacon
centric menu items the Big Mac with
bacon the quarter pounder bacon burger
and cheesy bacon fries okay what about
just cheesy fries could we could we get
that I'm sure you could I mean what
hours 4:00 to 5:00 on January 29th is
that today no that's next week so that
gives you ample time to like you know
hair put a meeting on the calendar and
run to McDonald's no does this also
apply on ubereats because you know my
fat ass like very rarely gets up and
goes to McDonald's I really just order
it um you're where each person would
have to like go there between 4 and 5
right nowyou I would place it like at 4
yeah and then you should write a note
like make sure they give the bacon for
free it's a special deal they're running
it send him the link to this article
like left out ISM though like so many
people can t bacon but I want something
free for McDonald it's like a McFlurry
yeah where everybody in McFlurry a toy
and oh really just like fries cheesy
fries
McDonald's is always doing like
innovative
I feel like you thinking that much like
this trashy company cuz like their
restaurants like smelly pee but they're
really like this marketing giant like
the biggest Cup it's literally the
biggest company in the world are they
owned by anyone or do they own other
things like Taco Bell is owned by Pepsi
I don't think McDonald's is owned by
anyone other than right crock of [ __ ]
right other than the founder make sure
you watch the founder if you haven't
already episode toast maybe in the week
but you might be a new toaster you have
to see the untold sort untold true story
of McDonald's or Michael Keaton and
Diane Keaton related I just thought of
that I don't know or maybe they're
married no Dan Keaton is too powerful of
a woman she can't she can't hold the
husband I don't know I love Diane Keaton
actually I feel she's another underrated
because I know you love her because
she's like a world-class actress with
like the Woody Allen and choosing the
Godfather but like I love her for like
because I said so and I will stand by my
statement that because I said so it's
the greatest movie of our generation I
know you're obsessed with her you're
obsessed with that movie that movie
first of all I love the song that they
continually use in that movie momma said
there'd be days like this
there'd be days like my mama said mama
said I just loved that song I loved
hanky I love Mandy Moore and I love the
older sister from Cheaper by the Dozen
Piper stating Ashton Kutcher coyote ugly
Lloyd Laurel Graham what's her name the
girl from our girls lore Lauren Lauren
yeah Lauren grim yeah love her and Diane
Keaton it's oh and then they also have
the really hot guy from suits which one
who's Jewish
Gabriel macht who's also from Gossip
Girl is he he's Serena's professor oh my
god yes so he's in it and then the other
guy I don't know his name and I don't
[ __ ] with him but wow there's a lot of
goodness there maybe I'll watch it it's
just have you ever seen it yes but not
start to finish you know first of all
it's like a sister's movie like the
sisters it's still gonna spit out food
many more it's just like is in it and I
just a Kimble it's just an it's a Nancy
Meyers right in have you ever watched
Grace and Frankie yes I think you would
like okay I started it and honestly like
so dumb and just like not into it it's
not my vibe but according to everything
or saying it like it is your vibe I
don't really like Jane Fonda
I mean she did she didn't capture my
heart and monster logs
but it wasn't enough I just don't really
like her and Georgia rule oh [ __ ]
take it back about because I said so
Georgia rule is the greatest movie of
our generation that should be it just
may be able to because I feel like a lot
of people haven't seen it even though
[ __ ] Lindsay Lohan's in it yeah and
oh my God look at that it's the drunk
right but the Jane Fonda is a grandma
that's the drum and then Jill hands the
daughter and she cuts limits hair oh my
god yeah oh my god I have to watch it
with me I feel like it's not on Netflix
it must be like you have to purchase you
probably buy Dynamis worth it worth
every dollar Wow and this was like
Lindsay Lohan had just like she was
starting to unravel but she was still
like glamorous and so pretty and had
just gotten out of rehab and this is
like the movie that was gonna bring her
back and what it did but then it didn't
you know yeah it was just an inch Oh
Garrett Hedlund oh my god this movies so
[ __ ] good from Country Strong yeah and
then who's the other girl who's like the
Gary girlfriend yeah who plays her Oh
someone good hug let let me Georgia rule
first of all just such a great movie
like such a great name such a great
little town they lived in such a great
cast Lindsay Lohan's outfits were so
premium but she was too good for this
little town in Idaho yeah I feel like it
was like Dermot Mulroney is in it oh my
god yes very hallmark I don't know I
need more time I feel like it was like
at the aquamarine girl Oh Sara Paxton
yeah if someone like that yeah it was
just a cute and Disney yeah maybe it was
Christine Larkin let me say it looks
like Brittany Snow I don't know whatever
anyways Michigan but just [ __ ]
amazing okay what was the story I don't
even know it was a McDonald's next up I
don't even know why the founder story
number we're on I think it's eight no it
feels like a P we're just breezing right
through NATO CB s rejects Superbowl ad
for medical marijuana ooh the Super Bowl
isn't ready for Medical Marijuana
acreage Holdings the multi-state
cannabis company backed by John Boehner
and is that the same person as the
government yes says CBS right rejected a
television advertisement that calls for
the legalization of medical marijuana
the network which is airing the game on
February 3rd makes the proposed spot
after seeing a rough outline according
to the company while medical marijuana
is now legal in more than 30 states the
federal the federal prohibition on
cannabis has restricted research made it
difficult for some potential patients to
get their hands on a drug that
proponents say helps treat seizures pain
and other ailments maybe I need to smoke
some Mary J oh god you know what I was
just singing that also it's legal in 30
states yeah I'd literally thought it was
like just California in Colorado no
medical matter I'm sorry their medical
marijuana Mountain medical marijuana is
legal in 30 states with medical
marijuana is not legal some places
that's yeah and now they want to get a
commercial to you know get people jazzed
about it I mean look I would maybe like
for my fatigue but I feel like marijuana
makes you more tired and paranoid and I
already am like so paranoid nobody it's
like and honestly I don't I don't want
to alter my mental state you don't I
mean my body feels tired and my body's
in pain so I want some ailment like to
help I want to help my body but I don't
want my brain to be I think I'm great
the way that I am yeah
this it helps with pain and nausea and
it sounds like all of my symptoms
you were nauseous yesterday I was ok
look I would try migraines make me not
like I would try it but like you would
need to lock me in my house and I would
need to have everyone around me like how
cuz I would be paranoid I'll be like I'm
gonna it's my family is my family ok I
don't need to bring snacks see like it's
just it's not the drug for me ok that's
fair the advertisements aim to quote
create an advocacy campaign for
constituents who are being lost in the
dialogue acreage President George on
said Superbowl airtime would have been
the best way to achieve this he added
quote it's hard to compete with the
amount of attention something gets when
it airs during the Superbowl very true
and then like you know the buzz
afterwards right CVS didn't immediately
reply to a request for comment on Monday
because it was a federal holiday or
because they just are dodging questions
I'm also like do they have to explain
themselves uh well is CBS a publicly
traded company yeah yeah I mean I I'm
sure they could explain themselves which
is that like you know it's too
controversial and like kids watch
exactly um I don't know I don't know
where I fall on
on the medical marijuana issue I stand
firmly in the middle because I don't
smoke weed I don't care about other
people who smoke weed as long as you
don't do it in my face in my apartment
or like make it smell in my house I
really don't care so I'm not gonna like
go to bat for either side and like make
people upset when I don't really care
and it's like do they Ayers tobacco or
alcohol commercials during the Superbowl
because if so oh they do beer oh they do
beer yeah do they do hard alcohol like
vodka yeah and do they do cigarettes no
cigarettes no commercials no anti
cigarettes have rails oh so mean yeah
Vegas to me you're answering cigarettes
then no marijuana but it's medical so
it's like do they do pharmaceuticals the
way I feel about marijuana's way I feel
about abortion it's just like doing it
and like leave me out of it you know I'm
not interested totes
well that's our SAS tensor right so
that's our best 15 I was a very fast 15
stories of the morning okay there's so
much TV to talk about let's to Deanna
from pearls I watched that first it was
such a good episode and it was really
like a rollercoaster of emotions for me
when it comes to Billy because I do have
to say when I watch the preview I was
like Billy sucks and when I was
following along on social media like
weeks months ago I was like oh this
[ __ ] is a thirst trap and there was a
point in the episode where she started
going off on people and I was like oh
she's crazy no even before that when she
came up to Kristen and Katie at her
brunch and she was being [ __ ] nuts
yeah the name were actually Kristen was
being very normal for Kristen or Mille
and like didn't give a reaction and
didn't start [ __ ] and I was very proud
of her and surprised yeah but like that
was really thirsty of Billy she was
being so nuts and at that point I was
like this [ __ ] is nuts then when she
said that she was left out and she was
like going around talking to people
about it I actually weirdly had like I
felt really bad for her like I was like
she has such a persecution complex like
no one is leaving her out and that
couldn't be more clear none of those
girls are transphobic like but she
really feels that way and I don't think
she was doing it to be thirsty I think
she really like has this complex of just
being left out her whole life that like
she's just again she was like again I'm
being left out I was like that's so sad
like to always just assume the worst in
people because for your whole life
people have been the worst to you then
she lost me again with the food thing
she could put the food down but for a
moment I had a little bit of empathy
for her understood where she was coming
from yeah I I tend to agree with that
but then it's like just because you feel
left out doesn't mean that you go and
slander like these people who and say
such untruth untrue and harmful things
about them and those kind of labels are
just like they stick so easily in this
leg cancel culture we live in they're
like you don't say it and don't like a
comment saying someone's transfer but
unless they really are right also agreed
completely lost me when she started
comparing her using her trans hard to
katie using her fac hard when it's like
first of all apples and oranges again
and it's like no people were calling
katie fat but he never threw down a fat
card she was like I'm fat leave me alone
and Hades not that I can't stress that
enough and it's honestly like so
dangerous for us to just be normalizing
like yeah like as if she's literally
like 600 pounds she just looked the most
normal average body underwater size six
so [ __ ] what I can't write and so no
one so people aren't calling he's on so
she's like I have a problem with being
called fat no one was giving Billy any
sort of [ __ ] about being trans no so she
doesn't have to it get it's like and
they have footage I wonder why they
didn't use that footage of four days ago
when Ariana was like by the way can I
invite Billy and Kristen was like I mean
Katie was like yeah but like I don't
want her help because they were fighting
at that point she had just come and
yelled at her a brunch right so like and
by the way there are plenty other of
other females who work at Sur who
weren't on the promotional poster
because there's no main characters and
they're not friends of them like where
was Christina Kelly I was thinking the
same thing
faith does she so work the Gigi the
hostesses yeah you know it's just so
stupid look for so many reasons she was
wrong but I didn't think that I didn't
think that she said she was left out for
reasons of thirst I think she really did
feel like she was left out because her
whole life she has been and I did feel
bad for her but the thirst with the with
the brunch conversation and then what
her conversation with Lisa was out of
control and the lack of self-awareness
that you're being an [ __ ] and that's
why you're not invited right and I'm
really surprised at Lisa like she's
handling this kind of poorly she's
handling a lot of things poorly yeah
like even making a mention of the fact
that like James is good for business
maybe we should keep him on even though
he's insulting all of our staff like who
gives a [ __ ] and no one also girl's
night looked so fun but then I was
thinking about James and what he did
was actually brilliant from going from
being a busboy to beggin Lisa to play
his CDs and his jams and to like he's
the only person who really made a career
out of working at Sur like a whole thing
out of it and now in combination with
sir right and no one else had that sort
of foresight so when he was saying like
people only their Tuesdays because of me
no but no what they would have never had
an injury delayed this if it wasn't for
James like really being sort of like
entrepreneurial he went from being a
busboy to like head DJ whereas they were
all waiters waitresses and and they
thought that was the top of bread
there's nothing else any like unless one
of them became like a five-star chef
Ryan became like this first sir but even
so that wouldn't necessarily bring in
new people so credit where credit is due
and that's why I think he's like so
upset that he got taken away and now
everyone's copying him it was a very
like he was very savvy back in the day
and we all were like making fun of him
he's a DJ hahaha
yeah but he DJ's we go to clubs and he's
the deejay yeah I swap meets own
performance he was pretty good even if
he's not like nobody even cares right
he's still got [ __ ] but he's a brilliant
businessman yeah um what else happened
in the episode Oh next week I know it
always says like next week looks good
but I need to know what happen with Lala
Ariana
well Lala's did an interview a few weeks
ago saying that at one point she was
dating a female cast mate like before
the show before I think she came on the
show I don't know it's very vague she
said you'll see more about it so I feel
like there's something there's like
history there yeah but like okay
whatever I like I actually can't wait to
see that um what else
Oh Brittany had him out down and I liked
about really bad first she definitely
overreacted but like I knew what she was
talking about she said we're gonna sit
down and film another conversation where
everyone's worried about me and my
liberal they should chef like leave me
alone and trust me and whatever and she
overreacted but like I did kind of feel
bad for though that she's the only
person who's like innocent actually like
leave her alone and also Katie was being
a [ __ ] yes we Britney and then when
Britney left Haiti was still talking
[ __ ] and not being a nice friend yeah I
think I might probably is nice for Katie
that like someone else's relationship is
under such a microscope now cuz like for
two seasons like two long seasons it was
all about her and Tom like yelling at
each other tequila Katie Tom hooking up
with a girl kissing the girl in Vegas
and now it's like the spotlights on
someone else is like let me
let's hound on that but I feel like if I
were her in that it happened to me I
would have had I would have
even more sympathy and I would probably
be grateful that is happening to someone
else but I wouldn't be the perpetuator
considering she knew how shitty it felt
yeah you know like I felt like she was
she was being a [ __ ] like in this
episode and yes she couldn't be more
empathetic when Jack James and Tom are
talking about like duck-duck-goose and
how they all follow each other like who
do you think there definitely is some
sort of like when they literally are
talking to Lala and they just like
change her mind about working with Josh
oh I thought about the with James
immediately like who's the head honcho I
don't know the number one girl in this
group I was thinking the same thing
because honestly I thought it was like
secretly Lala but just seeing her be
manipulated by them like literally
instantly I don't know I want to say
Katie I want to say so - she's just
influential in the group I that was wild
but she was like and they had a really
speak conversation the week before and I
really felt like James actually does
care about Lala like he doesn't care
about anyone I mean I think he cares
more about Lala than he does Raquel and
I think he really was gonna like make a
change and she just like was so easily
influenced that was so funny
yeah but I understand what they were
saying where it's like James needs to
hit rock bottom realize that they he has
no one there for him if you go into the
studio with him and you guys are like
cool then he'll think if everything's
fine again with everyone and go back to
his old ways but he really does need
like to be humbled and for more than
just one week and that this is like the
pattern of Vanderpump rules it's like he
gets fired he stopped drinking for a
week a humbled we start again
no like let's be real now like [ __ ] off
get him out of here Kristen was being so
funny in the episode honestly like I
treated which being like I really can't
stand her and like loving her no in this
episode I was just like I really really
like her yes she was said like so many
funny things she was being a good friend
to a lot of like I was just impressed by
her and usually I'm the first to just
blame everything on her yeah me too
because most of the time like you can't
trace it back to her weaselly ways but
she was being funny and she controlled
herself and I think they really did in
that brunch moment they really did not
want to give Billy like more camera time
so if they had made it into a big thing
it would have just given her like her
foot in the door like it would have
opened it so much more they were just
like whatever Billy and Billy could have
been like Kristen came to my brunch and
Brewin did right she keeps doing I think
she just like didn't give in which is
something that Juliet Porter needs to
learn okay see a newsroom or ski season
premiere two hours it was so good they
really amped up the high quality footage
like even more like it was just so
beautiful it's so beautiful I have a
hard time believing that the ocean in CS
ski is really that yell that blue know
it's such a beautiful show people city
everything it's so good - ours was not
enough last night because honestly I
went through like an emotional thing
where like I kind of liked Kelsey no see
okay so it's certainly getting me caught
up with everyone
Chloe befriended Kara they Chloe said
that they had been friends before but
obviously she brought her around just to
stir the pot and she and she admitted
that on this show yeah Hearns really out
or not on good terms at the moment in
the show Juliet now like seem to be
strong as ever stronger than ever which
is all relative and they are yeah and
they say I love you to each other and I
think that's a really big deal like who
else is Alex I would like to know
because analysis said I love you two in
a relationship because he definitely
goes around from garlic girl but does he
ever say that in this moment in time I'm
not hating Alex and Julia like they
haven't done anything to bother me yet
and he hasn't cheated on her so like I'm
fine right now
I'm fine right now to accept a I mean I
[ __ ] despise poly and what he did to
Jerry that was so terrible starting
allowed it a great a great a great of
room and we'll get there but I just so
that's the only reason why I'm like I
don't I would say you know Alex is
actually fine I don't hear he doesn't
bother me anymore except then he did
that and I [ __ ] hate him me too
but there's like a new character on the
show obviously there's new characters
but there's a new character and it's
money oh yeah no it's always been there
they've been oh but now they're talking
about it in a really direct like awkward
way about how age really it's only after
Alex for his money Juliette like was
talking about the way her
Alex screw up and then I heard grew up
was so different this new girl is like
so rich from New Jersey she's only
person who has just as much money is a
lease anymore yeah like in that those
types of conversations make me so
uncomfortable and like honestly I was
hating it but I love Kara's house and by
the way I would bet seven million
dollars homegirl just hired a chef for
the day oh of course
and like why do they have people rubbing
their feet like he didn't look like he
knew his way around that kitchen no
we'll get there but then there's also
the element of like these people are
doing well now they make money from the
show they have a ton of Instagram
followers they do
answered post so like right Madison had
to move home because she couldn't afford
a place so there's also a higher argue
in the show yes of who has money but
also who's a cheating must name who is
the most Instagram followers and like
Juliette it could like be driving a
Ferrari if she wanted to write her
Instagram money right at least not a bot
forever so it's like yeah these people's
their parents have money but who cares
no totally that's it's not even it's not
even relevant anymore and like alex is
his house is beautiful you know whatever
but he lives on the public beach no the
house is the weirdest thing ever and
someone explain to me wants in siesta
key there are no private beaches like
for a house to be built on so if you
want to live on the beach check you just
got a pop-up a house a next to a parking
garage and it's beautiful but it's
literally like the worst of the best
house on the worst block yeah you know
but why do I feel like Cara's house is
on a private beach Oh totally you know
yeah totally I loved her house yeah I
really liked Alex's house honestly I
thought Alex moved out last year did he
not he's he did and then when Juliet and
him got are talking about Chloe later oh
yeah they're in his house which is just
like a little frat house get on the
water got it got it got it okay so we
met Jarrod who I adore he's such a
little cutie from the military like
brothers in blue love him I just need
everyone to stop talking about high
school like it's serious do you don't I
mean like [ __ ] that happened in high
school is not real no I just can't
believe he came back for more and it's
like having the rest of the boys like
talking about his mathematics right
right and like bro you've been to war
yeah like how can you still hair like or
how can you even still remember and it's
like he never did anything to perpetuate
the fight with Alex but it's like he's
coming back and talking about high
school drama when like you've been to
war no and it's like even just coming
back years later and talking about high
school drama it's just stupid but it's
even more stupid when you've been to war
exactly when you've been to Iraq and
like where is the respect for those who
have served from paulien and Alex it was
a [ __ ] honestly I saw him they
should've been like thank you for your
service I'm a douche I wanna [ __ ]
start a petition to get Paulie off the
show I said we have Lincoln outside MTV
every year he does something even more
[ __ ] up like when he's just calling
Chloe fat last year like that's nothing
there is a special place in hell for
boys
girl's fat I will say that till the day
that I [ __ ] die and he did it so many
times he got arrested he's a disgusting
piece of [ __ ] and now this year he
literally attacked someone literally
Jared just took a step stood there and
got the [ __ ] beat out of him he didn't
have one word come out of his mouth
uh-oh said it's two against one and he
didn't even have any warning and it's
like why would you come to the party
like the whole [ __ ] it's a show a
public beach yeah I'm right I came to
the beach
totally also when they were like Paulie
was just drunk and hyped up like he's
definitely on drugs
yeah but also saying hyped up is that an
excuse no no but when they say hi to
buzz I mean like cocaine I believe so ya
know just like honestly I have such a
problem with Paulie like from an ethical
standpoint that something has to be done
change.org should we do it I think we
should do it he's so E but Alex Campos
dad is a producer and Alex and paulie's
like his cousin technically okay not
talking we're not related
Alex combos dad would probably be
grateful to like have this man stop
living off his dying yeah um he's a
grown man he can add like whatever
happened in his childhood very sad but
he can now take care of himself
get the [ __ ] off of my television my
television is too big and wide to see
your ugly face no my television when I'm
watching siesta key is to premium and
beautiful colors to see your little
ponytail okay I can't and I won't stand
for it like so even like it makes me
annoyed with Alex for sure that he
associate probably but then like oh and
Polly said the most [ __ ] up thing I
feel like you two are clashing because
you won't bend the knee or whatever so
you want something Aerys Targaryen like
so stupid yeah that's exactly right but
you're saying that as if it's a bad
thing like the reason why we're fighting
is cuz you won't respect and bow down to
Alex cos it's allergies have money and
live on a public beach right now it's
ready to go over the day it's so stupid
that got was so awkward I wanted to die
I wanted to die by the way let's make it
clear like they don't own that yacht
it's they rented it for the opening
which is just like if you're in the
people on your boat and like do that
like show I own a boat lately why would
you choose to meet like potentially your
future in-laws like it would be like me
renting Versailles right just for the
night
you know it was very odd I'm telling you
money thing is really awkward and looks
like now Garrett's like making money
stop with this train and the way when he
says his online business like it
literally sounds like porn took my
business make a lotta money I'm like a
guy born also fun facts right now in
time Garrett and Kara are dating in real
life yeah oh my like that me too
she's pretty but like she she's being
used as a pawn and she's loving and she
just like has to stop talking about Alex
like in the way that she is like I could
text Alex right now and he would come
over this second like please relax
but Juliet like need stepping someone
secure but also it's a part of the show
if she didn't react like there would be
no storyline so she has to react but I'd
be a little more secure she needs to
react she needs to stop reacting she
needs to be more secure everything also
for him I'm relay she's 21 years old
like these are lessons that you learn
like these are it's like she's making
all her mistakes in this relationship so
she's a better person in her next one
like yes we've all been through that and
we all know cuz we're all old and wise
but like she's just living and learning
and they're so young like you forget
that when Kelsey was like I was 20 as if
it was ten years ago right when they
it's very rare with this cast particular
that they're on the right side of
history but they really all were and
they took Juliet side in her verse Chloe
and actually spoke to Chloe last night
and she was like just please don't talk
to me until the third episode she says
that her comeuppance is coming yet and
just to bear with her we said after when
they came out we were like we love when
you guys are friends like please say
friends and code it's like you're gonna
hate me the first three episodes so I'm
baring like it's a Teddy Mellencamp
situation where it's like I love the
woman in person and on the show I'm
struggling to yeah but then when Kelsey
was like I'm team Julia and they were
like hugging I was like wait do I love
Kelsey when Kelsey was like when Cody
was like you hate Julian cuz there's
like yeah I don't like her but I'm on
her side right like it was so it was
sweet and also his honest it wasn't like
she was a fake like I'm gonna be uh
petroleum right now cuz she is most
popular person on the show and now she's
a narrator yeah she's like no I don't
like her but you're being a wrong that's
a good break in reality TV like you
usually just side with the person you're
friends with not the person that you
actually agree with so for someone to
actually just take the side of the
person they like less but because they
actually think that they're right and
deserve justice it's quite mature Kelsey
it's a big move so I was like a living
in love and Kelsey
also money is a new character and
Madison
haircut is a welcome new character oh I
couldn't agree less I think it looks so
bad oh my god no I thought her old hair
looks so bad you never knew how to do it
no I mean this is just like cute she has
a very like chic sophisticated look
about her to begin with she's like movie
star glamorous and she never knew how to
do her hair we were always like watching
her and her sister be there in the
bathroom and it's like please stop
so now she has a short hair look and
like it's less maintenance for her and
she looks great
and why is canvas like coming so hard
for Juliet like she's like I think she's
happened to be included on one of the
sides but like she everything that comes
out of her mouth it's like so mean about
Juliet she is very thirsty and like
she's not as secure for I felt I
remember no she's definitely still like
a friend of cat yeah and she saw what
happened to some of her friends last
season they didn't make the cut Hannah
Starr you and that other guy oh yeah so
she like no she's working ot but they're
they did make a good point with the
whole Alex Cara Juliet thing it's like
Juliet his best friends with Amanda like
best friends Amanda had sex with Alex
last year she's best friend no but not
best ones but she's friendly ish now
with Kelsey Kelsey had sex outside here
I think the difference is that when they
had sex with Alex a CR Julian amounts
were just hooking up they weren't I
don't think they were exclusive like yet
hurt her feelings but they weren't like
boyfriend/girlfriend they weren't in
love their relationship is very serious
no and to bring around a girl who has a
history of not giving a [ __ ] about
serious relationships like Technic like
when Alex was hooking up with other
girls like he was disrespecting Juliet
but he wasn't really doing anything
illegal
you know now it's it's way different and
way more serious and for Chloe to bring
bringing her around now just to drum up
drama in their relationship when they've
been through so much it's like they got
through all of that I regret now you're
gonna bring in like though it's like the
last person you have to fight yeah like
sure to go to New Jersey to pick her up
and bring her back yeah Chloe was being
a shady [ __ ] she was being a shady
[ __ ] but there's been like so much bit
in just the first episode like so much
physicality everyone's fighting like
physically I love it and I'm loving
Amanda she just she's so cute whoo like
I either love or I despise no yeah
everyone really like kind of grew up in
it over the summer and like everyone is
acting different you know I was like so
sophisticated it's Brandon we'll see
we'll see yeah but like he's selling out
his own shows we'll see and what was a
pose is really much does this be
I'd like someone when they're friends
with Juliet and I don't like them when
they're mean to her yeah but I just like
a love Chloe like I just want to protect
you it like all these other like Chloe
they're older than Juliet like they are
connived that's why they hate her it's
like I think she's like this young son
of fly sick bird and they just want to
protect her and she's so small when
they're small a guinea when she was here
I literally never saw like a smaller
person in my life not even just like
sheer weight like petite tiny small
narrow all of a small face small face on
the show you wouldn't think she had a
small face yeah but then she's here and
her face is smaller than stitches so was
Jared the only new character last night
yeah oh and Kara Jared was the only new
character that I yeah that I [ __ ] with
but I didn't hate Kara Khloe was really
like steering the ship of manipulation
but Kara was along for the ride and
that's just as bad agreed but also Kara
being like oh my god she knew if you're
gonna say [ __ ] like that you have to
text him right now but no when she was
saying that I'm like okay check sim but
she didn't which means she doesn't
actually think that she could do that
right she's full of [ __ ]
like but that that last scene at the
beach were like Club day like Amanda
like kicked Chloe off the beach of the
public beach was so wild like every
really last night was a premium ass
episode and I find two episodes to be
such torture because they very rarely
deliver like two hours of premium
content but there was two hours of
premium content there was and
something's changed with Kelsey maybe
because now that she's a model and like
she's more secure in her station in life
like she's just being like cooler mm-hmm
but when she was at the beach Chloe was
like not saying hi to her she's like
handling so well wait you know what the
chips and I was I wasn't gonna be rude
but okay my and Jesus walked away that's
so funny that you said that because when
she did that I had the same thought I'm
like wow this is a secure ass [ __ ]
because she was like I was she's like I
wasn't gonna ignore you and Chloe was
like well I was and she's like ok bye I
was like wow I wouldn't I never have the
balls to do that cuz I'm like such a
weenie I'd be like I don't yeah like I'm
a fake-ass [ __ ] alive and I was just
impressed by that scene as well me too
and now that I think about it was like
last year she was the new girl in town
so she didn't have that sort of power or
authority to be like I'm gonna
nor you like she literally needed
Chloe's friendship in order to even be
on the show but now that she's a main
character she might have more followers
than Juliet I have she does she always
has I haven't checked in a while I'll
check I so my things that like things
like that like I think she has the most
followers of all the cast members she
doesn't need to eat [ __ ] if Chloe's
gonna be a [ __ ] her die I'm going
swimming in my hot pink bikini with
Kelsey oh and my new haircut that is
very good Kelsey Owens 283 Madison house
236
I think Juliet's 268 as we try to find
oh by the way there were so many
commercials someone just mentioned that
I got a screener so I didn't watch them
Juliette 272 so Juliet is right
underneath Kelsey okay and let's see
where Chloe's out Chloe send ones 170
and I'm actually really curious to see
Alex kara like she's in one episode what
is that like 13 last night or something
okay how do you even find what's her
last name or - Chloe follows Oh smart
yeah Kara with a C right yeah this is
her I'm glad she follows me 17 chef's
follow her back no not yet she isn't she
honestly when we started when we both
started watching the show I was like
obsessed and the only person that
followed me was Kelsey I spoke so much
[ __ ] about her she did unfollow me I'm
gonna follow her back now cuz like
actually checking that one more episode
yeah yeah she keep it but she got no
respect last night she earned my respect
and I forgot about all the things that I
didn't like yeah because she seems to be
happy in a relationship she wasn't being
like thirsty with Garrett or anything
even though I do see that in a couple in
the print look in the future yeah I
don't you had a haircut and it looked
really good yeah so you know what I'm
pleased with everyone there were too
many commercials I didn't watch oh right
you watch the screener I actually watch
live even though I had a screener
because stage and I were watching live
together so it was I was like live
tweeting with snow so I've done
commercials but it did say on on the
thing property of MTV like on the whole
thing and it was so [ __ ] that so
annoying I can't have watched something
on my computer because of the migraine
so I had to wait till it was live no but
it was just like so pretty my man I'm
just like I'm so happy that this is a
show in Our Lives you know same and then
it's back yeah and we needed it we did
and I hope that Polly gets his ass
handed to him real soon really really
soon I wonder who Jared's gonna snuggle
up to I think I saw Madison
was that it hold on but there that guy
Madison's dating is so Hewitt Sookie but
it's not gonna laugh no not at all
wait I saw I start Kelsey hooking up
with someone her man Oh yep justice sir
Carson I saw his face for one [ __ ]
second yeah he's hot he's like a little
he was like supposed to be the Jared I
think yeah but he just didn't want it
enough yeah he like I don't think he
tested well yeah cuz there was something
very like weenie about him yeah yeah
okay well I'm really looking forward to
next week's episode you watch a bachelor
no I decided not to it's like once it's
Oh past the 24-hour mark like no one's
talking about anymore it might as well
have been a month ago yeah I believe
your New Mexico that way we'll talk
about it next week the only thing you
make suppose the pageant girl drama it's
so dumb they still won't tell us what
happened and I'm officially team Kaelyn
I'm not the kind of a yeah even though I
still don't know what happened but it
sounds like nothing happened then the
reason why I'm team Kaitlyn and not
Hannah anymore is because Hannah was the
one who brought up to Colton first and
now she's acting like Kevin's been
talking all that [ __ ] about me saying
horrible things about me she never
intended to talk about you until you
brought it up to Colton so when it's a
joke either this happening to me I feel
so misunderstood it's like you started
it you don't like how she finished it
good for her that she was able to pull
her name out of the mud with yours like
you started it so now like this is your
mess bringing drama to the bachelor or
the Bachelorette is like the easiest way
for you to become a loser yeah unless
the lead asks you what's going on in the
house you do not mention it and by the
way they could have both not liked each
other had some sort of weird beats like
I've seen it before but both be
individually good people when Hannah was
telling Colton she was like I just were
so different I don't know how you could
like us both it really worries me
basically that was her giving her an
ultimatum it's me or her and it's like
[ __ ] it's week two I'm gonna read a
very rough day you had a one-on-one last
week and it sucked ass you got by by the
skin of your chinny-chin [ __ ]
Jim so I'm I'm done with her okay good
you know well I'll take your side cuz I
believe you and I chose to you okay I
said it um and then at least went on a
date and she was a cutie okay
people are saying Elise for Bachelorette
I'm not so sure yeah oh I did see Margot
do that yeah Margot it said people using
Marta yeah and I think like one other
person
all right you guys thank you so much for
tuning in to the morning to us we're
back tomorrow we'll be recapping Real
Housewives of New Jersey exciting I'm
actually so excited it's my show on TV
um and thanks for being here to them
sorry I'm shy again thanks for being
here spending time with your favorite
millennial morning show hosts the
morning toast we will have Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
on YouTube and then we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found we love you and we will see you
tomorrow bye
you